[Musik]
bester nebendarsteller das ist für mich
die kategorie die mich einfach von den
namen her am meisten verblüfft hat denn
es ist wirklich die versammlung der der
alten weißen männer mit einer einzigen
ausnahme und die wird natürlich auch
gewinnen aber das ganze geht los mit tom
hanks geht dann so anthony hopkins
ich könnte diese rolle nicht mehr
spielen
ich dachte erst es ist ein film über
zwei päpste großer gott was will man aus
der story eigentlich noch so rausholen
aber anthony hopkins ohne johnson preis
dabei zuzugucken wie sie größten teil
eigentlich nur zu zweit miteinander
reden ist so wie ja wie in shakespeare
drama sich anzugucken also ist eine gute
dialoge und anthony hopkins das sowieso
die devisen sehr guter spieler also der
könnte durchaus nach schweigen der
lämmer vielleicht einen zweiten elvis u
boot das ist ja das ist wirklich lustig
völlig überrascht hat mich dieses jahr
brad pitt war für mich das beste an dem
film district superstar dort vergisst
das nie
keine ahnung wie die anderen auch nur
einen hauch von chance gegen ihn haben
sollten ich habe da gar nichts dagegen
ich finde den film zwar richtig doof
aber mit macht das einfach wunderbar
selbstironisch und er hat den oscar
sowieso längst verdient die anderen
haben glaube ich soweit ich sehe alle
schon also dementsprechend ist die sache
klar sein regen sind immer so lustig
anzusetzen ist mit dieser kamera gibt
dann immer ob jennifer aniston da ist
und das ist immer ganz anderes
eigentlich weiß nämlich ab die zu den
aus gas kommt aber brad pitt wesen aus
der gewinn nicht leider gibt es gar
keine frage
beim fernsehen arbeiten sondern bei fox
ja bei den weiblichen
nebendarstellerinnen da ist in gewisser
weise ein kompensations möglichkeit
gegeben denn scarlett johansson ist
sowohl als beste hauptrolle wie auch als
beste nebenrolle nominiert da sie die
beste hauptrolle nicht gewinnen wird
wäre jetzt eine sehr schöne chance für
die akademie sieht für die beste
nebenrolle auszuzeichnen also sie werden
auf ihn aufpassen während ich arbeite
sie geben ihm eine aufgabe damit er sich
zugehörig fühlt angekommen gekommen aber
auch das wird nicht passieren denn ich
glaube es haben sich schon so ziemlich
alle darauf geeinigt dass endlich
endlich endlich mal laura dern zum zuge
kommen sollte das ist direkt im app
store wo sie wirklich eine szene nach
der anderen gehen ebenfalls sehr sehr
guten hauptdarstellern eigentlich klar
erklärte man sei dabei die für mich eine
der tollsten schauspielerin ist die noch
mal so ein comeback geschafft haben in
den letzten jahren die unfassbar teuer
war in der neuen staffel die unfassbar
gut ist wenn maria story wo sie sehr
biestige anwältin spielte aber irgendwie
trotzdem ein gutes herz hat und einen
der schönsten feministischen renz
loslässt die dieses jahr im kino und bei
netflix in diesem fall auch wieder zu
sehen waren hart
schlagfertig super also ich bin mir
sicher dass die linke recht
ich habe es so satt denn die leute sagen
dass das liebe das einzige ist wozu eine
frau fähig ist die habe so satt aber ich
bin ich bin so allein beste
schauspielerin scarlett johansson marie
nicole liebe
sie ist eine tolle tänzerin
mitreißend
unfassbar bewegender film und sie
schafft es unglaublich gut diese rolle
zu spielen also das heißt sie hat so ein
moment wo er ist auf ihren schultern
liegt dass sie im kompletten rückblick
geben muss woran diese beziehungen ihrer
meinung nach gescheitert ist und wo man
normalerweise als regisseur einfach sein
würde okay wir machen da so gut blenden
wie sie erzählt dass also ein bisschen
aus dem oft rüber und in dem fall ist es
aber nur komplett auf ihrem gesicht die
kamera und sie erzählt gefühlte zehn
minuten lang von dem ende dieser
beziehung und es ist großartig und sie
schafft es das zu transportieren und sie
ist einfach sehr sehr gut sind der ego
in dem film harwich über harriet tubman
die es bei uns noch nicht gelaufen aber
ist eine von miss natürlich eine der
großen frauen figuren die das kriegen
bisher noch nicht sich angeschaut haben
und ja jetzt ist es so weit ich vermute
dass sie keine chance hat leider gottes
ja bei den hauptdarstellerinnen ein
einziger name renée zellweger das ist
die rolle die ihr auf den leib
geschneidert ist mit judy also dass die
hat die große biografische film wird
judy garland
ich finde das schade weil das sind zu
rollen und so filme die werden
eigentlich nur gedreht weil die jetzt
endlich mal wieder ausgebracht das ist
glaube ich auch bei den weg machen schon
jetzt bei den buchmachern schon jetzt
diejenige frau die mit abstand die
besten quoten hat ich fand ich an den
für mich so gut nicht so besonders gut
ich kann das da das thema doch
verschenkt war so um dass es eigentlich
geht nämlich die frage inwieweit wird
denn so eine hollywood biografie
tatsächlich zur zweiten haut und kann
man aus der überhaupt noch raus wenn man
das sie sind ein konflikt also es war
mir alles irgendwie zu wischiwaschi und
nichtsdestotrotz diese dame wird den
oscar kriegen natürlich kann man immer
wieder mal auf überraschungen setzen
aber in diesem fall würde sie nicht
geben wie es überhaupt wie gesagt bei
dieser oscar-verleihung sind wenig
überraschungen zumindest mit x1 schätze
geben wird renée zellweger ist die
gewinnerin ja vielleicht die einzige
kategorie wo zumindest für mich so etwas
wie spannung bei den schauspiel oscars
aufkommen wird sind die männer also
deswegen wirklich von diesem
abgetakelten serienschauspieler bei
tarantino über den papst zu alter ego
von almodóvar bester hauptdarsteller
sollte werden antonio banderas der wird
nie wieder so eine krasse gute rolle
kriegen 32 jahre habe ich gebraucht habe
ich mit diesem film zu versöhnen feiern
hier ist er wirklich so ein mann von
heute in seinem alter der ganz viel
erlebt hat und wenn es ganz viel
aussagen in dem sich ganz viel seines
lebens abgelagert hat und der arbeit
trotzdem obwohl ich am anfang so
aussieht noch gar nicht am ende erst
spät das wunderbar ich würde ihm
wünschen haben geheiratet heute große
schöne mein eigenes restaurant wasser
vor allen dingen geschafft hat war auch
spanisch einfach so viel besser zu
spielen als in seinen englischsprachigen
rollen also und wie macht es nochmal was
mit dem schauspieler wenn er tatsächlich
in der muttersprache loslegen kann und
das macht einfach umwerfend gut darin
spielt banderas so subtil und so
großartig auf den punkt das ist eine
schande wäre wenn er den preis nicht
bekommt aber er wird ihn nicht bekommen
ich wäre allein schon froh wenn es ein
bisschen spannender würde und man im
vorfeld noch mal darüber diskutieren
würde aber auch da läuft alles auf
schork in phoenix hinaus ja wenn sie
mich ankündigen wenn sie mich als circa
fürchten
ich finde das sehr kalkuliert ich finde
auch seine performance er kalkuliert ich
finde die anlage dieser figur sehr nah
am kitsch bettina fame mal so richtig
sagte um männern einen preis zu geben
müssen sie einfach nur eins tun nämlich
ganz viel abnehmen und enix hat
unfassbar viel abgenommen für diese
rolle und es ist sehr sehr dünn
es gibt eine szene wo ich so von hinten
zu sehen es war die die schulterblätter
so zusammenziehen und dann diese dünnen
knochen so aussehen wie so endet früher
das war für mich war eigentlich ein bei
diesem an diesem punkt der film gelaufen
wo ich dachte wollte mich jetzt hier
irgendwie auf den arm nehmen
also jedenfalls der wirt hier wird und
leider nicht der andere das war die
beste schauspielleistung die ich in
meinem ganzen leben gesehen habe
danke beste schauspielerin wiederholen
kann ich natürlich machen gar kein
problem sie ist ja auch großartig was
wie kann man der denn nichts geben